[Music]
welcome back Hannity and here is more of
my exclusive interview with President
Trump now I asked him about the North
Korean threat the Iranian nuclear deal
and so much more
take a look there was a lot of coverage
of your phrase they would report it in
the media cryptic phrase the calm before
the storm
it seemed related to rocket man his term
Kim jong-un in terms of him having ICBM
capability nuclear capability firing
missiles over Japan or Ally threatening
Guam and potentially maybe being able to
reach the United States continental
United States with a nuclear weapon at
some point this is going to come to a
head
what was the combo or just let this to
go on we just can now you can say what
you want this should have been handled
25 years ago it should have been handled
20 years ago and ten years ago and five
years ago it should have been handled by
numerous not just Obama but certainly
President Obama should have taken care
of it now it's at a point where it's
very very far advanced something has to
be done we can't allow this to happen
now China's been very helpful I think I
think you know who knows they seem to be
very helpful they cut off banking to
North Korea that's something they've
never done before they've cut down and
way down on the fuel and a lot of other
things we're gonna see what happens but
we cannot allow this to happen this
should have been taken care of long ago
Clinton gave them billions of dollars
gave them lots of other things and
before the contract the ink was dry on
the contract they were already starting
again with the missiles and with the
nuclear frankly so we are in a position
look we're very strong I've really I'm
building up the military like nobody's
ever seen what close to eight
the military our military was totally
from you know really depleted you look
around and you see what's going on you
take a look at what we're buying right
now with the jet fighters and all of the
equipment we're bike and you know it's
two things really
it is jobs and it's far less important
but we build the greatest military
equipment in the world we have missiles
that can knock out a missile in the air
ninety seven percent of the time and
have you send two of them it's gonna get
knocked out it fair to say if he keeps
firing missiles that's going to end well
I don't want to say anything I don't
want to say anything I'm just telling
you I don't want to talk about it
because you know all these people and
you're not using all the time with Mosel
we are going to be attacking Mozilla in
four months we're attacking Mosul in
three months until I say why do they
keep saying it attack do it or don't do
it or whatever but they kept talking
about it and by the way it turned out to
be hell on wheels it was hard because
they were so totally prepared and I'm
not saying I'm doing anything and I'm
not saying I'm not but we shouldn't be
talking about it calm before the storm
you're not going to talk about that
it was interesting Bill Clinton when he
made the deal with Kim jong-un's father
Kim jong-il he actually said this is a
good deal for the American people it was
not it seems the same mistake was made
with President Obama and the Iranian
deal there's reports you will decertify
this you can also pull out of it John
Bolton suggesting you just pull out
completely why decertify and not just
scrap it well you can do both to be I
will do both you can do both you can be
I and then I know exactly what I'm gonna
do it but I can't give it away tonight
but I'm gonna be announcing it very I
think it was one of the most incompetent
lead wrong deals I've ever seen a
hundred and fifty billion dollars given
we got nothing we got nothing
they got a path to nuclear weapons very
quickly and think of this one
1.7 billion dollars in cash this is cash
out of your pocket what you know how
many airplane loads that must be did you
ever see a million dollars like a
promotion with a half a million dollars
in hundred-dollar bills it's a lot of
this is 1.7 billion dollars you don't
much say who would be authorized to do
it and who are the people that deliver
it you may never see them again
right boatloads but just plain lows so
this is the worst deal we got nothing we
got nothing so I'm not giving anything
away but I've been saying this for a
long time you have people dancing and
screaming in the streets of a run now I
have to tell you those people are
possibly staged because I happen to
believe the people of Iran are great
people and they want freedom and they
want to be sort of friendly with us I
really believe that but they're dancing
in the streets and this they're singing
death to America and carries out they're
negotiating a deal and giving up every
single point he'd go in we'd like this
you're not having it done done done so
we're still I've ever said
whether it's countrywide or any other
one there is nowhere so so we will see
what happens produced a lot of people
are guessing but maybe there's not so
much guessing but it was an incompetent
deal look it was it's a very bad
deal I'm not saying anything different
tonight that I have been saying for two
years ago it's a horrible horrible
embarrassment to our country we did it
out of weakness when actually we had
great strength let me ask you about
immigration you came up with a 70 point
plan there was fear
after you had met with Pelosi and
Schumer and you were talking about daca
one of the things I've always noticed is
you'll we always get the tax increase we
never get the spending cuts you always
get the consideration on immigration you
never get the wall built part of it is
there will be you said no deal on daca
unless of course it's good we're going
to end chain migration you're gonna
build a wall that's going to be
see-through now so the we right now have
built five prototypes they're just going
up and some of them already finished and
I will say they're really looking good
they're really looking good and our
country needs it we need it not only for
people but we needed for the drugs that
are pouring into our country but we have
drugs in Israel and he was saying Donald
the wall works believe me they had an
open border that was like a sieve people
just poured in he said 99.9 percent of
the people now it stopped nobody gets in
nobody they say the walls how do I TiVo
it has to be built a properly built
constructed designed wall high not a
little fence like they'd have they'd
have they had walls that would solo
trucks would drive over them it was
easier to drive over it then to take it
down can you believe it okay so no
amnesty of the wall no amnesty no no ad
no chain migration the chain migration
is one of the disasters you allow one
person in and that one person brings in
ten or twelve people no daca until that
you fund the wall daca look we have
800,000 people they're not necessarily
young you know a lot of people think
their children I guess they average from
16 to 39 or so but a lot of these people
are in the military they have jobs after
said it's a very I fully understand it
but if we're gonna do some
thing we have to get something in return
and what I want is tremendous border
regulation I want the wall and we're
gonna get other things and we're gonna
see if we can work something that now
whether or not we do I don't know but it
would be wonderful to solve the daka
problem and by the way even my most
conservative hardline friends in the
Republican Party would like would really
like to be able to solve eight hundred
thousand people and honestly these
people went through a lot because most
of them went through our system many of
them don't speak the language of their
country because they've never been to
their country so we are going to try and
solve that but if we're going to solve
that we want a wall and we want great
border security
[Music]